À l'aide !
Calmez-vous !
Regardez !
Je suis comme vous !
On est dans la même merde,
j'ai une chaîne aussi.
Oh putain...
Je suis désolé, j’ai cru que...
J'ai cru que j'avais été pris en otage
par des musulmans, j'ai...
Non non, c'est juste...
Quoi ?
Vous voulez dire terroristes, non ?
Ouais.
Oui c’est ce que je viens de dire.
Non justement vous avez dit...
Qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent là ?
On est où, il se passe quoi ?
Je sais pas trop,
je viens de me réveiller aussi.
Mais en regardant autour ce qui est sûr,
c'est qu'on a affaire à un psychopathe...
Ou pire...
À un fanatique de l’islam.
En fait ce que j'essaye de dire c'est que rester ici
peut faire de nous des hommes morts.
Ou encore pire.
Des hommes convertis à l'islam.
Je pense que c'est la situation
qui vous perturbe pas mal et...
Ce que j'essaye de dire,
c'est qu'on est deux justement.
On peut s'entraider pour trouver une solution...
Il y a sûrement un moyen de sortir d'ici non ?
Vous pensez pas ?
Je vous laisse chercher,
vous avez l'air de savoir.
Coucou vous deux.
Vous devez être complètement effrayés je sais.
Vous avez le privilège d'avoir été choisi
comme participant à ce test psychologique.
Vous voulez vivre, n’est-ce pas?
Et bien, le jeu est simple.
Vous possédez chacun une arme à feu
que vous trouverez sur votre gauche.
Les deux armes contiennent une seule balle.
À vous de les utiliser à bon escient.
Si à la fin de ce compte à rebours
il n’y a pas l’un d’entre vous qui est mort...
Un gaz mortel va inonder la pièce.
Lequel de vous deux va survivre à ce petit jeu ?
Et bien je vous laisse en débattre...
Allez putain !
De toute façon c'est un connard.
Ça se voit que c'est même pas un mec bien...
C'est qu'un gros cist-ra de sa race là...
Vous avez trouvé un truc là, une issue ?
Non je...
Ils sont plus doués qu'ils en ont l'air finalement...
D'ailleurs par rapport à ca...
Je peux vous poser une question ?
Allez-y...
Est-ce que vous vous considérez comme raciste?
Ah non.
Non je suis juste lucide.
Faut ouvrir les yeux un peu...
Vous comptez pas changer d'avis par rapport à ca ?
Ah non. Ce serait se montrer faible d’esprit.
Ils me font pas peur hein.
Vous assumez complètement tout ce que vous pensez
de A à Z, à 100 % ?
Oui, oui.
Absolument.
Et en même temps...
J'ai un peu envie de vous dire que
c'est peut-être lié à l'éducation que m'a donné mon père.
Parce que quand j'étais petit c'était très...
Comme ça à la maison, et pis...
Et pis c'était compliqué de penser par soi-même
donc en fait...
Vous avez peut-être raison oui.
Sinon à part ça vous détestez les musulmans...
Ça c'est un... c'est établi chez vous.
Non je les déteste pas je...
Disons que je les comprends pas.
Oui mais vous les détestez enfin...
au fond vous les détestez !
Mais non je vous dis que non.
Mais si vous les détestez putain !
Je vous dis que non putain !
Mais vous avez touché un point intéressant...
Effectivement quand j'étais plus petit mon père m'avait amené...
Putain mais tu vas avouer que t'es un raciste de merde ?!
Oh je le savais que vous étiez l'un d'eux.
Putain depuis le début je me le disais en fait...
Et puis moi je vous fais confiance parce que je suis sympa.
Et vous vous savez que trahir !
Vous savez que répandre le mal autour de vous !
Et bah allez-y tirez !
Moi j'ai pas envie de vivre dans un putain de monde où vous existez de toute façon !
Alors-tirez ! Tire-putain !
Tire aie-les couilles !
Regarde-moi dans les yeux et tire !
Vas-y ! Viens !